these
phones are the best phones we have ever
created and the reviews have been off
the charts it doesn't get any clearer or
any
better than this review from one of the
industry's preeminent reviewers Walt
Mossberg said simply it's the best
smartphone on the market you can't hope
for better than
that for more on what Apple has been
unveiling in the last minutes I want to
get back to our Sam grobart in New York
with the latest Sam who's Walt Mossberg
I'm just kidding I've been watching the
event as it's been unfolding and
audience favorite Craig federi is still
on stage he's been talking about the two
operating systems that Apple has of
course iOS 8 and Os 10 and what he's
been talking about is how closely they
are working together more and more and
how iCloud is providing the link between
those two os's it's a very different
approach than say Microsoft who wanted
to build a single operating system for
both mobile and desktop devices and has
found that that can sometimes be a
little bit of one and not enough of the
other Apple has remained pure to
maintaining two different operating
systems but with all the new features
that they're announcing things like
handoff and continuity and iCloud Drive
the work you do on one device can
immediately be picked up on another you
can send text messages from your desktop
you can look at keynote presentations on
your phone basically it doesn't matter
which operating system you're using the
work flows between the two of them